Em buong ba tháng 12, các bạn nghĩ thú trong 3 năm, công an tình đồng này đã thông tin bàn đầu vụ sức người,
cứ tài sản sẻ ra tại sả đất nhau. Tình đồng này.
Thế đó, sáng cùng ngày, công an tình đồng này dịch được tin báo của người dân về vụ băng người thú bóng chưa
gió miến tải lý túm mua nông sản thiên hạnh để chiế thu a sấu, sả đất nhau.
Ngay sau khi nhận tin báo, lực lượng công an đánh in trong chiếc hai lực lượng để hệ chương,
phát hiện băng người thú bóng của ông Đỗ Duy thiên.
Xin năm buồn miền chỉ trong 7 mi tám, chuẩn nhà cho đối phyền tế, Xin năm 2018, cho ngoại ông thiên,
và 8 chương hồng hạnh, Xin năm 2018, buồn ông thiên.
Qua kiểm tra bàn đầu, khi những các bạn nhìn từ vóng trên người có nhiều thương tích,
tài sản và vật sự trong nhà có sự sạo trụ.
Hình công an tình đồng này đã chỉ hai các bị phát nghiệp vụ chuyến bắt đối tượng.
Công an tình đồng này kêu hỏi mọi người dân nếu phát hiện đối tượng kể an hoặc có thông tin liên quan.
Khi thời của cấp để số địa thoại không ba sảo năm, ba sâu sấu, bày bày bày đông chỉ lê vấn,